안녕하세요. 모두를 환영합니다.
활성 추론 게스트 스트림 28.1입니다
. 2022년 10월 14일입니다.
오늘 우리는 Giovanni
Rolla의 합리성을 재고하는 것에 대해 듣고 토론
할
것입니다. Giovanni
는 이 프레젠테이션과
토론을 기대하고 참여해주셔서 대단히 감사합니다.  감사합니다
감사
합니다 두어 달 전에 초대를 받아
기뻤고 제 작업에 대해 논의할 기회를 갖게 된 것을 기쁘게 생각합니다
um 요청을
아끼겠습니다 um 우리 제안
내가 몇 년 전에 썼던 논문
과 어 우리가 무대 뒤에서 이야기하고
있을 때 나는 내 생각이 몇
번 바뀌었고 나는
그 논문을 출판한 이후 프레젠테이션 중에 이것을 분명히 할 것입니다. 그러나 그것은
기쁩니다  그럼에도 불구하고
이 비디오를 여기에서 발표할 기회를 가질 수 있고
어 세상과 공유할 기회를 가질 수 있어 매우 기쁩니다
어 그래서 우리는 합리성을 다시 생각하는 것에 대해 이야기할
것이고 이것이
여정입니다
제시할까 하는 생각이 들어서 먼저
합리성과 내용 없는 인지에 대해 이야기 하고
나서
근본적으로
소극적인 합리성과 안전
에 관한 나의 견해를
제시할 것
입니다.
첫 번째는
내가 여기에 있는 것이 무엇이든
지나치게 자유주의적인 면에서 진정한 자유주의자라는
것이고, 두 번째
반대는 내가 생각
하기에 당신이 가장 관심을 가질 만한 것은
그것이 효과와 양립할 수 있는지 여부입니다.
우리의 예측 코딩에서 예측 프로세스를 사용하는
것은 물론 시설
에 있는 두 대의 자동차 근처
에 있어 적극적인 영향을 미치기
위해 여기에
있습니다. 죄송
합니다. 이 문제에 대한 나의 초기 생각
은 전통적으로 매우 정통적이라는 것입니다.
합리성에 대한 견해를 가지고
어 내가 아는 한 대부분의 가정은
합리성이 자신의 추론에서 반드시 그래야
한다는 가정입니다  ance 나는 Bure
를 보증하는 추론이 있는 경우에만 행동에서 B가 합리적이라고 믿습니다.
물론 그것은
어떤 추론도 아닙니다. 추론 질문
은 uh 고전
논리 또는 확률 추론 또는
이 전통적인 영화에 따라 합리적으로 믿고 행동하는 휴리스틱
은 특정 형식적 기준을 충족해야 하며
, 내가 말했듯이 이것은 합리성을 추론의 관점에서 정의하는 것이
합리적이라는 것이 무엇을 의미하는지에 대한 가정인 것 같습니다.
추론이
특정 형식 벤치마크에 대한 믿음의 평가를 포함하는
경우 합리성
은 콘텐츠가 최소한의
정확도
를 갖는 것으로
간주하는 콘텐츠를 의미
합니다.  여기서의 생각은 합리성은
필연적으로 신념을 포함하는 내용을 포함한다는 것입니다.
추론 및 비교 또는
죄송
합니다 지금 업데이트
하나의 소프트웨어 업데이트
여기 내 창에 팝업
이 있었다
죄송합니다.  내용 그것은
고전적 인지주의 또는
인지주의 일반
에 잘 맞는다. 이것은 결합이
필연적으로
최소한 일부
인지주의자들에게는 표상적 내용을 포함한다는 견해이다. 물론 그것은 개념적 내용도 포함할 수
있지만 최소한
그러나 이 고전적 관점
은 그다지 좋지 않아
근본적으로 비활동적이고 구체화된
인지
와 잘 맞지 않습니다. 어, 최근 책
에서 Goodwin Maine의 급진적 및 행동주의에 대해 구체적으로
생각하지는 않지만 다른 문제에도 도전한다고 생각합니다.
급진적이고 적극적인 것으로 제시되지는
않지만 물론 그들은 급진적이고 활동적인 일부
핵심 임차인을 공유합니다.  sm
우리는 그것들을 어 Ezekiel Powell 또는 Berman 감각 모델 생활이 제시한 관점과 함께 음과 같은 인지에 대한 근본적으로 구체화된 관점이라고 부를 수 있습니다.
당신은 또한
Gallagher의 다양한 비활동주의가 그의
2017년 책에 있고 또한 Tony kimero가 그의 관점에서 본 것을 의미합니다.
생태 심리학 및 역학
시스템에 관한 2009년 책 그들은 모두 공통의 임차인을 공유
합니다. 저는 이것이 매우 논쟁의 여지가 있다는 것을 알고 있습니다.
그러나 저는 이러한
견해를 인지에 대한 근본적으로 구체화된 견해로 취급
하고 있지만 특히
요리에 대한 급진적이고 적극적인 견해에 초점을 맞추고 있습니다.
그들은 모두 인식이 내용이 없는 표상적 인식이 아니라고 말합니다. 내용 없는
기본
형태의 인식
이나 자신의 환경에 대한 적극적인 탐구를 통해 나타나는 내용 없는 수준의 기본 수준의
인식
과
급진적 행동주의를 넘어서  이것이
의미
하는 바는 이 아이디어가
감각 운동 참여를 마스터한다는 점
에서 현금화될 수 있다는 것입니다.  -물건이
당신
주위에 있다는 것을 아는 대신에 당신의 주변에 어떻게 관여
하는지 아는 방법은 Paulo와
동료들과 어 kimero
가 그들의 책에서 예를 들어 매우 명확하게 하는 것입니다 어 급진적이고 행동주의
는 왜곡하는 경향이 있습니다  감각
모델 교전 감각 모델 계획
등등
그리고 어
, 하지만 최근의 발전
에 따르면 이것이
바로 이 아이디어의 요지를 사용하는
것이라고 생각
합니다
합리성 우리가 가지고 있는 것은 앵글이
다음과 같이 기술한 것입니다
. 행동주의는 인지
가 기도에 근거를 두고 있다는 견해입니다.
실생활 상황의 감각 운동 습득에 기초한 세계에 대한
합리적 이해이며 그는 이것을 설명합니다
.  세계
와의
관계는 p에 뿌리를 둔 단 하나일 수 있다는 멜로펜틴 하이데거의 관념에 의한 합리적 이해
비활성 연기 및
실습 인턴은
신체를 통해 중재되므로 여기서 암시하는 것처럼 보이는 것은
연기 및 실습과 달리
합리성은 실제로
매우
기본적인 조합 수준에 있지 않은 것이므로
우리가 할 때 일어난 일입니다.
능동적이고 실제적인 인지의 기본 수준을 위한 공간을 만들고
그것들이 일반적
으로 합리성의 운 좋은 고전
이라는 상위 수준의 결합과 분리합니다.
운동
참여는 합리적이지
않으므로 감각적 현대적 참여 그러나
다산의 미덕
은 합리성의 관점에서 평가될 수 없습니다
인지에 대한 내용만
높은 수준의 조합은 합리적
정의가 될 수
있습니다.
나는 종이에서 다루지 않았지만
그것이 나의 암묵적인 동기였습니다.  마음의
철학에서 나온 사람으로서 이 주제를 다루는
것은 신화의 아이디어입니다.
주어진 최소한의 버전은
그 당시에 나에게 보였습니다.
그것은
나의 초기 발표에서 매우 복잡
했지만 우리
가 합리적인 생각과 행동에서 기본 인식을 분리
하고 우리가 우물을 가리키지 않는다면
이 두 수준 사이의 교차점이 없다는 것을 의미합니다.
급진주의와 행동주의 그리고  어 비슷한
견해는
Sellers에 의해 대중화되지 않은 주어진 신화와
McDowell에 의한 중재가
내 마음의 지배적 인 분야에 대한 문제로 전념 할
것이므로 이것은
[Music
] 철학적으로 흥미로운 문제라고 생각하는 것 같습니다.
그러나 그것은 그런 것이 아닙니다.  어
, 논문의 최전선에서
우리가
감각 현대적 참여를 통해 내용이 없거나 기본 수준의 인지
를 비율과 결합하는 방법을 설명하는 것이 내 암시적 동기였습니다.  만약
당신이 할 수 없다면 어,
어
, 우리의 마음의 그림에서 완전히 설명되지 않는 일종의 주어진 것이 있는 것 같습니다.
그래서 이것이 제가
원했던 것입니다. 저는 여전히
이 직관을 더 명확하게 탐구하려고 노력하고 싶지만 저는
이
음에
대해서는 언급하지 않았지만 오늘
제가 보여
드릴 것은 주어진 것의 신화에 전념한다는 이 비난을 트위스트하는 방법인 것 같습니다.
그래서 우리가 합리성을 어떻게 다시 생각할 수 있습니까?
나는 그
문제를 피하고 우리가
서로 완전히 분리된 두 가지 수준이 있다는 생각을 피하기 위해
하나는 상위가
고전적 합리성을 궤적하고
그 아래에 있는 것이 합리적이지 않다는 생각을 피하기 위해 합리성
을 거부하는 것이라고 생각
합니다.  정의되어야 하거나
필연적으로 추론을 수반합니다. 추론
은 여전히 ​​생각할 필요가 없지만 추론이 아닌
경우 합리성이 무엇인지에 대한 긍정적인 제안을 제공하는 것이 도전이 됩니다.
여기 Susan H가 있습니다.
내 지식이 이 주제에 관한 유일한 지식이고
그녀도 당시에
주어진 신화에 대해 걱정
했다고 생각합니다. 그는 여기에서 긴
인용문을 인용했습니다.  서로 다른 수평 계층 간의 억제 촉진 및 조정
의 중앙 집중식 계층 관계의 복잡한 시스템에서 나올 수 있습니다.
각 계층
은
수평적 또는 모듈식 용어로 재구성된 동적 및 환경적 합리성입니다. 어
그녀가 이 용어를 사용해야 하는지
모르겠지만  어쨌든 그것이 그녀
가 그것을 표현하기로 선택한 방법은 환경과 지속 가능하게
관련되어 있습니다
. 유기체
전체 또는 수직으로 묶인
중앙인지 모듈에 대한 내용과 같은 입력과 출력 사이를 중재하는 내부 절차에만 의존하지 않습니다
.  n의 특정 측면
을 모니터링하고 응답하는 레이어를 포함하는 전용 World 간의 복잡한 관계
자연적, 사회적 환경
과 신경망
의 반응으로부터 피드백을 줄인다
는 것은 내가 아는 한
어떤 사람이 어떤 방식으로 비활성
접근 방식으로 작업하는 가장 초기의 경우이며,
이는 분명히 활동가
이기도 한 아바노의 작업과 더 일반적으로 연관되어
있습니다.
급진주의와 행동주의와는 다른 접근 방식으로, 그리고
제가 그 논문을 쓰기 전에 제가 아는 한 가장 초기에 그리고 제가 아는
것은 합리성에 대한 가장 명확한
제안이
네이티브 용어로 인식되었지만 그것이 그녀의 출판 이후
주목을 받은 것은 아니라는 것입니다.
내 지식은
실제로 그 이후로 많이 보지
못했고 아이디어를 요약하자면 합리성인
설명 초점을 변경해야 한다는 것
입니다. 합리성은
이 제안에서 용량을
포함하는 콘텐츠로 독점적으로 생각되지 않습니다.
그리고 그것이 근본적으로 구현되었는지
여부는 신체 형태와 작용
, 그리고 유기체가 어떻게 위치하고 행동하는지에 달려 있습니다.
s 그 환경에서 그 아이디어
는 최소한으로 죽을 것이므로 이것이 내가 근본적으로 비활성이라고 부르는 것입니다
합리성
은 어 매우
느슨한 정의에서 지금까지 아시아인
은 인간
이 그녀의 인지 능력을 조정하는 그녀의 환경과 능숙한 상호 작용을 유지하는 한 합리적으로 행동한다는
것입니다
제약 조건
및 견고한 스테이션의 환경 조건에 따라 물론
예상치 못한 상황에 적응해야 하는 경우도 있습니다.
핵심 직관은 이것
이고 2003년 그녀가 쓴 텍스트에서 Susan Hurley의 다른
아이디어와 급진적이고 능동적인 합리성에 대한 아이디어를 비교하는 것은 흥미롭습니다.
그녀는 연기에 대한 이유를 말합니다. 그녀는
연기에 대한 이유
가 그녀가 가레스 에반스의 일반성 제약에 대해 논쟁하는 맥락에 구속될 수 있다고 주장하며
, 이것이 실천적 합리성의 섬이라는 관념의 방어
이기 때문에 그녀는 여전히 합리성을
본질적으로 관련된 것으로 취급하고 있습니다
여기서 추론하지만 이런 종류의
추론은 한계가 있습니다.  d 실제적인
맥락에서 볼 때 이것은 매우 진보적인
견해입니다.
제가 처음에 이야기한 전통적인 견해와 비교할 때
그러나
여기에서 발전
시키려고 하는 것보다 여전히 더 보수적입니다.  제안
은 합리성이 행위자 및 자율성을 의미한다는
것입니다. 왜냐하면 유기체가 하는 어떤 것 또는 단지 어떤
것이 합리적 권리라고 할 수 있기 때문입니다.
그래서 이것을 사용하기 위해 uh
자치 및 활동가 진영과
플레이어에게 어떻게 하는 가에 대한 이론으로부터의 아이디어는 다음과
같은 자율 시스템입니다.  룸바
는 에이전트가 아니기 때문에 합리적일 수 없습니다.
자체 행동의 작성자가 아닙니다.
외부
에이전트에 의해 특정 방식으로 작동하도록 설계
되었으므로 엄밀히 말하면 국가
가 아닙니다.  예를 들어 합리성을 Roomba에 돌리는 것은 이치에 맞지 않습니다.
이를 위해
저는 DiPaolo와 다른 사람들의 자율성과 적응성의 개념을 사용합니다
.  또한 최근 책은
4가지 감각 모델의 삶과
2005년에 나온 유명한 논문을 이미지화하여
러시아인이 된다는 것이 무엇을 의미하는지에 대한 매우 일반적인 제약을 설정하는 적응력에 대해 이야기
하므로 자율 시스템이
불안정한 네트워크로 인식됩니다.
조직과 물리적 경계가
시스템 자체에 의해 생성되기 때문에 불안정한 프로세스 네트워크 시스템
은 자체 유지 관리에
유리한 환경
환경 조건을 탐색하는 의미 만들기
로 알려진 자체 생존 조건을 지속적으로 유지하고 있습니다.
그것에 해로운 것들을 피
하므로 이것이 바로 이것이 내가
합리적 존재
에게 그것이 자율적 시스템이어야 한다는 감정적 제약이 있다는 바로 일반적으로 이해하는 방법
입니다. 여기서 흥미로운 점
은 Paulo가 말한 적응성 개념이
네 번째는 유기체가 자기 생산의 조건을 개선하는 능력입니다.
h 내부
구조적 변화가
있으므로 가장 유용한 행동 방침을 선택
하기 위해 내부 변화의 모니터링과 규제
를
포함한다는 것은 근본적으로
비활성인 합리성 개념의 아이디어를 포함하는 데 생각하는 또 다른 흥미로운 개념이라고 생각합니다.
추론과 내용에 반드시 전념하는 것은
아니므로 환경 제약 및 변전소
에 따라 유기체 내에서 변화를 촉진하는 상황 능력의 행사를 통해 대리인이 실현됩니다. 이는 유기체
가 환경에
능숙하게 대처하기 위해 얼마나 잘 적응하는지를 의미합니다
합리성의 표시 또는 표시가
합리적일수록 유기체
는 환경을 다루기에 더 적합
하고 우리는
상황
을 예견했으며 그렇게 함으로써 유기체는 생존과 환경에 결정적인 환경과
자신과 환경 사이의 지속적인 교환을 강화합니다.
그것은
합리성에 대한 매우 자연스러운 사고 방식입니다.  생존을 위한 변화를 강화하는 능력이 대부분입니다.
이것이
여기의 전반적인 아이디어입니다.
그래서 앞서 말했듯이 추론에 대해
말하고 싶습니다.
나는 합리성을 반드시 추론과 함께 저지르고 싶지는 않습니다.
이것이 근본적으로 비활성적인 합리성이
모든 것입니다. 그러나 나는
이전의 합리적 조합으로 추론을 배제하고 싶지
않으므로 내가 말하는 것은
추론에 의해 정의
되지는 않지만 어 그렇지 않습니다. 추론 추론을 배제하지 않습니다.
나는
합리적 행위의 특별하거나 특정한 모드로 생각할 것이라고 생각합니다
그것은
인간에 대한 우리의 지식에 배타적
이지만 합리성의 정의적인 특징이
아니므로 이 아이디어를 설명하기 위해
나는 Hutu와
Saturn 사이에 있는 utani의 가장 최근
책에서 그들이 설명하는 방법을 기억합니다
높은 인식의 출현 아이디어는 인지를
위한 콘텐츠에 참여할 수 있다는 것은
궁극적으로 콘텐츠 전체 인지가 사회에서 나온 사회 문화적으로 내장되는 것에 달려 있다는 것입니다.
개인이 사회
문화적 실천에
참여할 때
상징을 다루는 더 오래된 인지 능력
을 받아들이고 그렇게 함으로써
문화화의 긴 과정에서 당연히 내부적
이지 않은 상징적 조정에 참여할 수 있게 됩니다.
표상
은 공개적으로 이용 가능하기 때문에 특정적이다
. 전통적인 의미의 정신적 표상은
아니지만
내부 표상이나 심적
표상에 대한 헌신이 없는 상징적 인지의 특징을 가지고
있으므로 가장 일반적인 의미에서 합리적으로 행동
하는 것은 능숙한
행동이라는 생각이다.  유기체는 그 환경에서
유기체의 능숙한 행동
이며 체화된 능력의 조정에 의존
하지만 모든 것이 잘되면 추론
은 물론
나의 특정 합리성 모드에 대한 합리성을 위한 내용으로 이해됩니다
추론
은  사회 문화 속의 유기체
en  물론
우리 환경의 보다 구체적인 측면인
환경은
문화적
으로 기반을 두거나
인간 계통 발생 규모에서 더 최근의 능력을 포함하는 콘텐츠의 조정에 달려
있습니다. 이것이 가장 큰
아이디어입니다.  제 생각에는
어 긍정적인 부분이 있고 여기
에 제가 첫 번째에 대해 이야기하고 싶었던 반대
가 있습니다. 그것은 매우 자유주의적인
견해입니다. 매우 음, 좋습니다.
합리적인 행동이 조정으로 귀결된다면 너무 많은 것을 포괄하고 있기 때문입니다.
인지 능력의 경우 합리성은
유기체에 대한 점진적인 것입니다. 환경 상호 작용
에 다소 능숙할 수
있으며 거부는 근본적으로 비활성 합리성에 따라 진행됩니다.
많은
유기체
가 성공의 다른 수준으로 틈새 시장에서 적응 행동을 달성하고 유지합니다
음 음, 누군가가 자유당에게 합리적
이고 능동적인 급진적이고 적극적인
합리성을 노래할 수 있습니다.
내가 개인적으로 들었던 한 가지 반대 의견
과 나는 그것이 매우 좋은 방법이라고 생각하기 때문에 그것을 열심히 유지했습니다.
손톱이
이 보기에 합리적이고
내가 구매할 의사가 있다고 말해야 하는 것입니다.  지갑
어 글쎄, 그것은 전통적인 견해보다 더 자유 롭습니다.
물론
그렇게 의도되었지만 나는
이것이 그 자체로 문제라고 생각하지 않습니다.
여기에서 긍정적 인 부분은 그것이 인간
의 정도의 차이를 보존한다는 것입니다.
다른 동물보다 훨씬 더 합리적입니다. 우리가 알고 있는 다른 동물보다 훨씬
다양한 역동적인 상황에서 다양한 행동을 수행할 수
있기 때문입니다. 이 못의 예로 돌아가서
이 못은  몇 가지 복잡한
작업을 수행할 수 있습니다. 한 지점에서 다른 지점으로 이동할
수 있습니다. 음식과
피난처 등을 찾을 수 있습니다. 그러나
이 못을 남쪽으로 둘러싸면 능력이 매우 제한적
입니다. 예를 들어 다음과 같이 죽을 운명입니다.
반면에 반박과 인간
은 훨씬 더 적응력이 뛰어나고
많은
예상치 못한 상황에 동적으로 대처할 수 있습니다. 그래서 어
그 반대에 대한 제 대답은
그렇습니다.
음 글쎄, 그것은 매우 진보적이지만 그것이
문제가 되지 않는다면 문제가 될 것
입니다.  그것은 동물이 환경을 다루는 방식 사이에 정도의 차이가 있을 수 있는 여지가
있고 이것이 다른 대상
이의제기라고 생각합니다
. 가장 관심이 있는
것은 12가지 예측 처리입니다.
유추와 내용을 암시하는 것
같지만 처음
에는 어, 이 글을 쓸 당시에 여러분과 시청자에게 경고해야 합니다. 어 이 백서
는
행동주의와
예측 코딩 또는 예측
처리를 결합할 가능성에 대해 훨씬 더 낙관적이었습니다.  여기에
중요한 요점이 있다고 생각하지만
Olu와 Evan Thompson
과 Randy 맥주의 최근 논문이 있습니다.
e
주로 ​​자유 에너지 원리와
음
비활성 및
자전적 이론을 결합하려는 시도이므로 이제
대부분의 주장에 확신이 섰지만
그럼에도 불구하고 여기
에서 우리의 예측
코드와 어  내가 글을 쓰고 있는 시간
과 오늘날까지도 인지 과학은 열광하고
있습니다.
과자 소리가
주요 패러다임 중 하나
가 되었다고
말할 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이 뷰어에서
경쟁
은 양방향 좁은 계층에서 발생하는 오류 최소화 프로세스로 이해
되므로
불길한 자극의 원위 원인을 예상하는 하위 계층의 활동에 대한 내부 모델 생성이 있습니다.  하향식
프로세스 및
예측과
현재 자극 신호
간의 불일치 최소화  예를 들어
Clark의
공식적인 용어를 알고 있는 비공식적인 방식으로 이해되는 능동적 추론이 있습니다
. 유기체는 감각적 결과를 생성하는 우리 세대
에서 능동적으로 추구하는 방식으로 센서를 움직입니다.
그들의
두뇌
는 이것이 매우 형식적인 용어에 영향을 미치는 능동적인 것을 이해하는 한 가지 방법
이라고 생각하지만 제 생각에는 그것이 일을
끝낸다고 생각합니다.  예를 들어
, 제품 편향과 추론 권리를 사용하는 예측 처리에 대한
그 투표 독해는
지각
주의자의 과정이 증식 및 맥락 하향식 효과의 합리적이고 광범위한 편향 과정과 분리될 수
있다고 말합니다.
이것을 처리
하는 것은 Clark이 또한
합리성에 대해 계속 이야기하고 있는 방식으로 내 주의를 끌었
지만 그것은  n 추론적 종류의
합리성
과 만연한 영향 요인 추론은 비
침투적인 내용을 암시하는 것 같
으며 예측 처리는
근본적으로 비활성
적인 합리성과
잘 양립할 수 없는 것 같습니다.
-치질과
예측 처리의 읽기
예를 들어 첫 번째 단계
는 2013년의 짧은 논문에서 카메오를 이해하는 디플레이션 감각을 사용하는
것이지만
두 개 이상의 변수
값이 공변하거나 신뢰할 수 있는 값인 네 번째 단계입니다.
값이 1이면 관찰자가
다른 값을 추론할 수 있으며 여기서
추론은 관찰 수준에서 발생합니다.
멀리 있는
변수가 아닌 다른 변수의 값을 추론하는
것이므로
내용이 사람의 눈에 있다고 생각합니다.
관찰자 우리가 넣은 검열의 선택이
여기에서
이해된 내부 예측에 근접하는 방식을 해석하는 사람  그는 인플레이션 감각이
그것을 추론적이고 편향된
용어로 설명할 수 있으므로 이것이 내가 예
를 들어 내가 틀리지 않으면
제목이 뇌는
과학자가 아니며 그 주장은
과학자들이 뇌 활동
을 뇌 자체의 특징으로 해석하는 이 일반적인 방향은 마치 뇌가
더
강력하거나 더 무거운
감각을 예측
하고 추론하는 것처럼
그리고 더블은 영어로 이것의 이름을 잊었다고 합니다
죄송합니다
음 그것은 문자 그대로의 의미가 아닙니다. 어
근본적으로 비활성에 따른 추론의 의미
어 합리성
은 공동 지향적인 행동의 효율성
을 위해 무장하지 않은 것입니다 에이전트
는 자신의  그 또는 그녀의 상태가
더 적은 비용으로 더 효율적으로 결실을 맺는다
는 것은 생성 모델 자체가 예측 추론을 표시하고 수행한다는 더 논쟁적인 주장을 의미하지 않습니다.
es 이것은 급진적이고 능동적인 합리성과 함께
이 조합을 제공하기 위해 예측 처리에 대한 매우 디플레이션
적인
해석입니다.
여기
모델별로 2018년
의 논문에서 시작합니다.  이 모델은
인지 작업입니다. 대신
유기체는 모델인 일부 표현형을
반영하는 일부 환경에서 인과적 및 통계적 규칙성이 반영
되는 모델
이며
이는 최근에
uh 내 동료에게 알림과 내가  유기체와 환경이 역사적으로 결정되었다고 하는 행동주의에 따라
유기체가 어떻게 세계를 낳는가에 대한 아이디어에 대해 이야기해 왔으며
, 따라서 흐름 유전적 규모에서 이것은
틈새 구성의 아이디어를 통해 설명될 수 있습니다.
유기체는 환경에서 활동적이며
충분히 안정적이면 변화를 촉진합니다.
그들은 자손에 의해 유전 될 수
있으며 이러한 변화
는 진화론 적 경로를 이끄는 새로운 진화론적 압박 압력을 제공합니다
. 비슷한 아이디어는
이번에
Niche Construction
과 생태 심리학과 관련된 다른 설명에서도 탐구
되었으므로 그 반대에 대한 나의 대답은 다음과 같습니다.
합리적으로 행동한다는 것은 예측 및 최소화
를 통해 환경에 능숙하게 참여하는 것을 의미합니다.
나는
그 특성화를 기꺼이 받아들입니다.
무의미한 예측과 그것들의 최소화
는 입력의 선택과
상호작용의 조정을 수반하는 세계 관여 방식의 조정을 포함하는데,
이는
정확히 급진적이고 적극적인 성격의 주요 주장
이므로
예측 처리가
아니라 오히려 적일 것이라고 생각합니다.
uh 도착이 아니라 c의 이 아이디어의 거짓말보다
여기에서 다루지 않은 다른 호환성 문제가 있습니다. 하지만 오늘 생각한 것은 어입니다.
정말 감사합니다. 정말 감사합니다.
질문을 작성
하겠습니다. 메모를 수집하고 먼저
토론을
시작해 보겠습니다. 다시 한 번 말씀해 주셔서 감사
합니다. 현재 위치에서 이러한 질문을 하게 된 경위와
이 분야에 대한 관심이 어떻게 발전했는지에 대한 약간의 맥락이 있습니다.
흥미로운 아이디어가 너무
많고 어떻게 이 프레이밍을 하게 되었고 요점을 날카롭게 했는지에 대해 더 알고 싶었습니다.
좋아요 감사합니다 좋은
질문입니다.
이 배경을 탐색할 수 있는 경우가 많지 않기
때문에 중요합니다. 그래서 어 저는 당시에
제가 박사 학위 논문을 쓰고 있었던 것 같아요.
아마도 2007년쯤이었을 겁니다. 그리고 어 저는
합리성은
궁극적으로 세계와 관련된 것이어야 한다는 생각에 대해 논쟁하고 있었습니다.
내가 너희들 사이에서 보여줬던 것처럼 잘 생각하는 경향이 있다. 어,
체화된 시대에 사람들
과 연기, 연습 등과 같은 본질적으로 세계가 수반되어야
하고, 물론 지각이 있어야 하지만 합리성
은 남아있다.  귀화
할 수 있는 관념 같은 것 그것
의 수준으로 내려갈
수 없는 것 어떤 동적인 참여 등
으로 설명될 수 있는 지각과 같은 방식으로 축소될 수 없는 것
그래서 당시 나는 그렇게 생각하고 있었다.
아마도
이것은 무릎 문제
일
것입니다. 다른 상황에서는
어떤 지각이든 전문적인 조합과 특정 적합성
을 제공하는 방식으로 명확하지 않은
경우 지각이 주어진
것이며 이것이 주어진 차원의 신화임을 암시하는 것으로 간주되기 때문일 수 있습니다.
처음에 그리고 나는
이것이 아마도
활성 인지에 대한 여기에서 작용하는 주어진 신화의 무언가가 있는 것일지도
모른다고 생각했지만 이것은 아니라고 생각합니다
우리가 원칙적으로 주장할 수 없기 때문에 치명적이지 않습니다. 왜냐하면
개념 등을 포함하는
계단 인식 및 기타 기본 형태의 조합을 해석하는 대신 다른
방향에서 주장할 수 있을 것입니다.
그래서 그것이 동기
였고 매우 긴 검토 과정이었습니다.
제 첫 번째
논문 버전은 시청자가 매우
옳았다고 생각합니다. 저는 그들이 전적으로 옳았다고 생각합니다. 저는
결국 그 제안을 지지했지만
그는 매우
어  그 부분을 굉장히 단호하게 맡았고
또 다른 문헌이기 때문에 더 좋았다고 생각합니다.
또 다른 uh
입니다. 활동주의와 신체 인식과 함께 일반적으로 대화에서 다루지 않는 많은 언급
이고
단지 그것을 넣는 것이 매우 어려웠습니다.
같은 용어로 내 주장을 발전
시키는 것이 중요하므로 내가 긁어 낸 것입니다. 나는
그 시스템에 대해 너무 많이 생각하지 않았지만 그것이 내가 원하는 것이라고 생각합니다.
그리고 아마도
어 아마도 지난 몇 년 동안 누군가가 그렇게 했을 것입니다
나는 기억이 나지 않지만
행동주의와 선물의 신화 사이의 이 관계는
매우 분명한 것 같습니다
그래서
우리가 할 수 있는 일이라고 생각합니다. 어, 탐구할 수는
있지만
신문의 최전선에 있던
것은
아니지만 모든 의미에서 합리성에 대해 이야기하고 싶은 생각이 들었습니다.
당시 나는 철학적 관점에서 그를 불렀다에 대해 많이 읽었습니다.
물론 나는 말했듯
이 접근 방식의 기술과 형식에 정통하지
않지만 거기에서
철학적 결과에 관심이 있었고
잘 생각했습니다.  아마도 여기에 비교해야 할 것이 있을 것입니다.
왜냐하면 Clark의
인용문 쇼처럼
당신은 합리성에 대해 끝까지 이야기할 수
있고 어, 그것은 제가
발전시키고 싶었지만 인지주의적 관점이
아니라 근본적으로 구현된 영화가 아니기 때문에 발전시키고 싶었기 때문입니다.
그것이 배경입니다
굉장합니다 감사
합니다 주어진 신화가 무엇인지 설명해 주시겠습니까
그 신화가 생겨난 맥락은 무엇
이며 주어진 신화를 제기 한 후 우리는 어디로 가야합니까
? 나는 그것을 개념으로 보았 기 때문에  당신
은 내 철학의 당신의 취향에 따라 몇 가지 가능한 Gives가 있지만 가장 고전적
으로 마음의 이전 분야
에서 인식의 내용을 주어질 수 있도록 주는 중간에 그것에 대해 어떻게 되었습니까?
우리가 생각하는 특정
입력을 가지고
있고 마음이 그것을 해석하는 방식으로 합리적으로 기도하여
판매자 다른 판매자
는 어 이 문제를 마음의
연료를 증가시킬 뿐만 아니라 문제로 설명하는 것으로 유명합니다.
합리주의자들에게
그러나 다른 한편으로 이성적인 것은
일반적으로 어 이성 직관이 주어진 것으로 간주됩니다.
다시
말해서 어, 분명하지 않은 어느 정도의 인지 수준이
있다는 것입니다.  s 주어졌거나 어떤
사람들은 사육되는 것에 대해 이야기
하지만 어떤 면
에서는 주어지는 인지의 수준이 있고 마음
이 그것을 해석해야 하지만
이런 식으로 주어지면 접촉점이 없고
무엇이든 간에 교차점이 없습니다.
마음이 무엇을 하든, 그리고 이 기본
수준의 어 지배
는 주어진 것의 신화에 전념한다는 비난을 피하는 것이지만 다시 이것은
원주민 문헌에 명시되어 있는 것이 아니라
내 말은 어 이런 종류의 비교에서 발전하는 것이 가능하다는 것을 의미하지만
명확하지 않은 것이 아니라
지븐스가 지각적 내용이 본질적으로 이미 개념적이라고 말할 수 있도록 문제를 해결하는 한 가지 방법입니다.
예를 들어 Joe McDowell
당신이 인식을 더 많이 알고 있다는 것을 염두에 두십시오
어 농담은 자막과 함께 제공되며
당신과 세상
을 당신이하는 것처럼 해석하지만 어
어떤 식 으로든
당신이 합리성을 알고있는 신비를 풀기위한 것이라고 생각합니다  그리고
조합의 상위 레이어
는 그것들을 생각하려고 uh uh 덜
uh
커밋하지 않고 분석용 콘텐츠이므로 엄밀히
말하면 조합의 기본 수준과 분리된 수준의 콘텐츠로
생각하는 방법 중 하나입니다.
합리성은
일반적으로 전적으로 인간적인 것으로 가정
하고 추론과 관련된 것으로 가정하기
때문에 합리성이 이를 수행하는 한 가지 핵심 개념인 것 같습니다. 그렇다면 합리성은 행동에 정보를 제공할 수
없으며 물론 행동이 본질적으로 내용이 없는 경우라면
그래서
합리성이 본질적으로 만족스러운 감각이고
반응이 본질적으로 콘텐츠
가 없는 것에 대해 억제되지 않는다면 당신은 이것을 가질 수 없습니다
uh 그것은 끝났습니다 이 uh
두 영역 사이의 교차점이며
이것은 내가 피하고 싶었지만 내가
말했듯이 그것이 너무 어려워졌습니다
이 견해를
충분히 명확하고 일반적인 방식으로
표현하는 것은 리뷰어의 추천에 따라 그 부분을
긁어모았고
나는 여전히 나에 대해 생각한다는 것입니다.  t 하지만 아무
것도 내가 할 수 있는 것보다 더
명확하게 다룰 수
있는 적절한 논증
을 개발하지 못했습니다
생물학적 기능으로서의 합리성과 피트니스의 관계로 그래 그래 그래
그래 난 음
내 생각에 그것이 본질적인
관계라고 생각한다 정말 난
그게 어 아마도 가장
[음악]
음 특별한 규모
에서 합리적 행동의 명백한 결과라고 생각합니다
우리
는 합리성이 uh 특정 종의 특징인지 또는 개인 대신에 있는지에 대해 이야기합니다.
저는 피트니스가 이것을 이 uh 합리적인 행동의 결과
로 생각하기 위해 여기에서 핵심 개념 중 하나라고 생각합니다.
그래서 내가 아니라고 말하지는 않지만
그것을 논문의 그 문제에 넣어라. 나는
그것을 합리성을 생각
하는 것에 대한 이의로 보지 않고 당신이 아는 그런 식으로 생각하는 것이 가능하다고
생각합니다.  o
모든 살아있는
유기체가 아직 본능적으로 가지 않았다면 어떤 방식으로든 이 결과를 받아들이고
환경에 적합하므로
최소한의 합리성을 포함할 수 있음을 기꺼이 보고 싶습니다.
적의 변화하는 환경을
다루지만 글쎄요 그리고 그것은
매우
자유주의적인 합리성에 대한 진보적 개념을 갖는 대가입니다
이것은 그것의 결과
라고 생각합니다
그래서 당신은 피트니스
가 합리적인 행동의 결과라고 말했습니다
다른 결과가 있거나
개미
군락
이 이성적일
정도로 번성하고 있다는 말 외에는 외부에서 합리성을 어떻게 인식합니까?
그렇지 않으면 단순히
그것에 의해 설명되거나 su에 의해 반영된 결과로부터 합리적이거나
비합리적인 행동과 같이 분리하는 데 사용할 수
있는
결과가 있습니까?  리바이벌과
휘트니스
맞아요
이 개념을 잘 살아서 연기하는 관계라는 점에서 모든 것이 사실이거나 이성적인 IPS라는 식으로 이 개념을 사소하게 만들고 싶지 않기 때문에 매우 신중하게 생각
해야 했습니다.
어 특정한 경우
에 국가를 식별할 수 있다고 생각합니다. 나는
그 틈새 시장에서 개인과 평등합니다.
그래서 개인 수준에서 특히
좋습니다. 이것은
분류자가 비합리적인 정도로 분류할 수 있는 결정적인 특정 행동입니다.
어 생존에 해롭지만
어 종 수준에서는
이런 종류의 행동이나 결과를 식별
하기
때문에 그런 식으로 논쟁
하는 것이 더 어렵습니다.
생활은 인수분해되어 하나의 생존에 해가 되는
이러한 종류의 특정 행위를 식별해야
하므로 개미 식민지의 경우에는
아마도 모르겠습니다.
침략자를 환영하는
것은 일종의 행동이 될 것이므로 생존에 해가 될 것입니다.
이것이 무엇인지 모르겠습니다. 어
, 이것에 대해 생각할 수 없는 방법 중 하나입니다.
더 명확하게 생각해야
했지만
제  조심스럽게
오 매우 흥미롭고
Eco Evo
Devo가
Niche 건설이
느린 계통 발생 과정과 보다
빠른 발달 과정 사이의 간격을 연결하는 방법을 보다 생물학적 관점에서 보는 것처럼 여러 중첩된 시간 척도와 같은 프레젠테이션에서 답변을 가져왔습니다.
음 그래서  이
내재된 다중 규모 고려
는 콘텐츠 개념과 어떻게 관련이 있습니까? 콘텐츠
가 한 본문에 국한될 것인지, 콘텐츠
가 엔터티 간에 배포되는지 또는
합리성이 엔터티 간에 배포
되는지 여부와 같이 합리성의 위치를 ​​식별하는 방법
과 그  또한 귀하가 제공한 인용문에서
um 수평 및 모듈식 개념을 호출하여
두드러진 부분을 식별하는 방법
관심의 공간적 시간 척도 및 시스템
오 아 나는 잘 모르겠습니다. 어이 완전히 대답할 수 있을지 모르겠지만,
어 수준
에서 예를 들어 콘텐츠에 대해 이야기하는 경우
정확성으로  상징적
사고의 조건 다행스럽게도
그것이 한 개인에게 국한된 것이 아니라 공개적으로 공유
된다고 말해야 한다고 생각합니다. 그래서 당신이 말할 수 있는
한 가지 결과는 정보 사이트가
된 다양한 추론 패턴을 생각할 수 있다는 것입니다
다른 시간에 등등 그리고 당신
은 그들이 다른
수준으로 다른 수준의 콘텐츠 정보에 대한 다른 규칙을 개발했음을 알 수 있으며
콘텐츠가 현지화되어 있다고 말할 수 있다고 생각
합니다.
어, 어떻게 당신이 세부 사항을 아는 양을 공유한다고 말할 수 있습니까?
합리성을 위해
[Music]
특정 행동을 식별할 수 있다고 생각
합니다. 만약 그것이 적합하다면
uh 회전에
능숙한 상호 작용과
적응력  유기체와 환경 사이의 상호 작용
틈새이므로
합리성과 내용으로 여기에서 다른 답변
을 제공할
수
있습니다.  다른 사람들의 양과 이것은
적어도 60년대부터
나의 철학자들이 가지고 있는 것입니다. 나의 철학자
들은 내용이 외부적으로 개별화된다는 생각을 주장해왔고
어 나는 이것이 하나의 비디오라고 생각합니다.
예를 들어 힐러리 퍼트넘(Hillary Putnam)
과 타일러 버지(Tyler Burge) 등은
정신적 내용이
커뮤니티 수준이나 사회적 수준에서 개별화
되지만 다른 한편으로는
합리성이 원칙적
으로 특정 행동으로 개별화될 수
있다고 생각하지만 개인의
목표와  그것이 서식하는 틈새
등
물론
여기에는 행동을 식별하는 데도 중요할 수 있는 실제 변수가 있습니다.
이성적이든 아니든
감사합니다
음 글쎄요 한 구절
이 저에게 정말
꽂혔습니다
오늘 여기 그
용어가
어떻게 다루어지고 오늘날
의 행동과 실천과
노하우가 어떻게 다른지 알지 못합니다.
음
, 아주 현대적인 철학에서 나온 경향
이 있긴 하지만
인지과학의 첫 번째 물결
에서 지각
을 환경을 범주화
하고 이산적인
예를 들어
내가 알고 있는 컵이 내 왼쪽
에 있다는 것을 인식하는 것과 같은 환경적 측면에 대한 설명은 그러한 속성을 검색하는 것이 있다는 것을 아는 문제입니다.
내 왼쪽이고 이것은 일종의 어 알다시피
세계에 대한 일종의 명제적 태도이므로
어 나는
행동주의와
생태 심리학에 대해서도 흥미로운 점이라고 생각
하고 미국의
실용주의를 초기부터 회상하는 정도
세기는
인식
을 세계의 이러한 위대한 속성을 범주화하는 문제가
아니라 어
연기 가능성을 공개하는
문제로 생각해야 하는 것입니다.
t
커브가 내 왼쪽에 있다는 것을 알면서도 컵을 잡는 방법을 아는 것과
커피 한 잔을 마시고 싶을 때 또는 그것을
문진은 다른
침묵하는 속성을 가질 것이고
이것은 비록
그랬지만 나는 행동주의와 생태
심리학, 그리고 인지에 대한 다른 구체화된 견해
가 대체로
성공적이었다고 생각합니다.  이 논의를 여기까지 하기
전에 나는 어 보다
전통적인 인지 과학에서 당신은 여전히
환경을 설명함으로써 유기체 유기체가 잘 인식
한다는 생각을 가지고 있다고 생각합니다.
어, 예측 처리에 대한 보다 전통적인 판독이
어 명확하게 하는 것입니다.
당신이 자극의 근원에 대해 추론하고 있다는 생각
과 그렇지 않다는 생각
과 마찬가지로 뇌나 인지
시스템이
세상이 존재한다는 것을 알고 있다는 생각이 더 쉽게 받아들일 수 있다는 뜻입니다.
의제 시스템이
세계와 소통하는 방법을 알고 있다고 말하는 대신 환경이 그렇습니다
. 활동가와 생태
심리학자가 만들려고 하는 요점은
코딩 및 자유 에너지 원칙
등은 이러한 개념이 이러한
프레임워크가 kubernetes 시스템이 참여하는 방법을 알고 있다는 최소한의 아이디어가 될 수 있음을 보여주는 것입니다
.
ge inboard 요약을 읽을 필요가 없는 방식으로
Kindle 시스템
이 세상이 그러하다고 추론하고 있으므로 이것이
설명하는 방법 중 하나라고 생각하지만
철학적으로도 처음에 큰 문제가 있는 경우
지난 몇
십 년 동안 어,
클라우드가 그것을 알기 위해 축소될 수 없었는지 여부에 대한 거대한 토론
, 그리고 다시 당신이
이것과 다른
것에 대한 배경을 가지고 있다는 것을 당신으로부터 독립적인 개념으로
알고 있고,
하나를 다른 것으로 축소할 수 있는지 여부 등  그래서
나는 그것이 거기서 그치지 않는다고 생각합니다 당신은 할 수 없습니다
uh 내가
어떻게 다른
사람이 어떻게 노하우를 취급할 수 있는지 여부의 배경 문제라는 것을 알고 다른 사람이 지각적이라고 주장할 수는 있지만
어쨌든 이것은 그런 것입니다.  저도
최근에 작업 중입니다.
특히
언어적 의사 소통에 있어 매우 흥미로운 아이디어입니다
. 손가락과 달과 약간 비슷하고 달에
대해 이야기하지만 손가락은
단지  그것이 어디에 있고 우리는 참조
에 대해 이야기하고 있는 포인터에 대해 이야기하고 있는 것이 아닙니다.
따라서 문화 언어나 서면 학술 담론에서
사회인지적 형태의 의사 소통을 사용하여
그것을 살펴보거나 그것을 다시 상상하고
보이는 것까지도 볼 수 있습니다.  피나클과 같이
그것을 알고 있는 것과 여전히 그것을 아는 것으로 보는
것 제 생각에는
우리가 논문을 어떻게 읽는가 하는 것 같아요
예 물론 예 제 생각에는 어
,
어, 그래, 그럴 수 있는 가치가 있는 것 같습니다
당신이 언급한 것처럼 이러한 부정적인 능력을 노하우의 문제로 취급하려고 하면
예를 들어 우리가 여전히 의사소통
에 대해 뭔가를
놓치고 있는 것처럼 보이기 때문에 매우 큰 문제입니다.  우리는
원칙적으로
당신이 방금 말한 것을
이해하고 그것에 대응하는 것이
언어적으로 어떻게 행동해야 하는지 아는 문제에 대해 이야기할 수
있지만, 나는 이러한 움직임조차도
높은 수준의 인지 학자를 치료하기
위해  t 노하우의 문제는
여전히 ​​무언가를 남기고 있습니다
. 저는 개인적
으로 의미하고 만족합니다. 어느
정도는 우리가 어떻게 설명해야 하는지에 대한 또 다른 종류의 접근 방식이라고 말할 수 있어야 한다고 생각합니다.
예를
들어 의사 소통이 필요하지 않다고 말할 수는
없지만 지금
은 적어도
실용적인 지식 이상이 필요
하다고 생각하는 것이 아니라 아마도 여기에서 핵심은
실용적인 지식
을 다른 종류의 기본적이고 필요한 것으로 생각하는 것입니다.  이러한 종류의 교환에 참여하는
데 필요한 다른 종류의 지식에
대해서는 아마도 이것이 하나의 계층일
것입니다
. 더 유익한 답변을 제공하기 위해
이에 대해 더 많이 말해야 한다고 확신합니다.
적어도 나의 현재 입장
은 우리가 세상과 다른 사람들과 어떻게 관계를 맺는 데 기초를 제공하지
못하지만 어떤 시점에서 우리는 복잡한 종류의 어를 설명
하기 위해 다른 종류의 이해를 발전시킬 수 있어야 한다는 것
입니다.
말씀하신 대로 논문 읽기와 같은 일상 생활에서 우리가 하는 교류
저도 동의합니다.
틀을
짜는 방법을 기초로 알고 복구하는 것이 도전이고
기초적인 인지 과정부터 시작하는 것도
어려운 일입니다.  그
노하우 조각을
다시 조립하여 단순한
도전이 아니라
상징적
명제적 선언적 언어적
등 인지 과정을 보다
한계적인
생태학적 인지 접근 방식에서 조립하는 도전에 직면
하거나 튜링에서 생태학을 복구하려고 시도할 것이라는 것을 알기 위해
어떤 의미에서는 기계를 사용하여
생태학적으로 그럴듯한 기초 인지 과정의 기초를 지지
하고 고층 빌딩
을 조립하기 위해
노력
하고 있는 것 같습니다.  당신
이 이런 종류의 설명을 제공하라고 말했듯이
왼쪽 아래 또는 위에서 아래로 하지만 저는
물론 웹
접근 방식이 더 유리하다고 생각합니다. 다른 이유로도
우리
가 세상과 상호 작용하는
방식에 대한 생물학적 설명인 것처럼 보이고 그 반대의 경우 훨씬 더 어려운 것처럼 보입니다.
어 우리가 어떻게 신체 형태
와 같은 생물학적 질문을 생각해 냈는지 설명
하려면 먼저 그것에 대해 설명해야 하는 것 같습니다.
그러면 대답하기 어려운 다른
질문에 도달하게 됩니다.
적어도 제 생각
에는 상향식 접근 방식이 더 어
통합적이라는 점에서 기회
가 더
어 의미에서 우리에게 유리한
것처럼 보입니다.
컴퓨터를 처음부터 프로그래밍
하려면 추상 또는 가상 컴퓨터가 될
수 있으므로 특정 구현이 필요하지도
않으며 이러한 상황에서 이러한
선언을 주장하고 조립하는 데 관심을 가질 수 있습니다.
좀 더 역동적이거나
환경과 상호 작용하는 것으로 에이티브 진술과 논리 프로세스
를 처리하지만
논리 및 실리콘을 기반으로 하는 풀 스택 엔지니어링과 같은 프로세스는
우리가 여기까지 온 방식과 상당히 다르기
때문에 그럴 수도 있지만 상호
보완적입니다.
당신은 어에 대해 약간의 가시성을 주었습니다.
어, 피어 리뷰 중과 후에 있었던 것 같아요.
그래서
저는 지난 몇 달 또는 몇 년 동안 또는 얼마나 긴 기간 동안 이 논문을 작성하는 동안과 이후에 어떤
변화가 있었는지 궁금
합니다.
그것이 당신을 위한 것인지 아니면 그냥 일반적인 것인지 여부에 관계없이 다음 단계가 관련성
이 있다고 보십니까? 우리
는 뇌 측정을 찾고 있습니까? 우리
는 숲에서 비디오 카메라를 찾고 있습니까? 우리
는 개념을 찾고 있습니까? 진보
앞으로 나아갈 것  당신의
발전
은 그것이 좋은 질문이라고 생각합니다
음
나는 내가 외국 레벨을 사용하는 방식에 완전히 만족하지 못합니다.
t in uh 나는
당신이 원칙적으로
다른 경험적 용어로 수행할 수 있는지 솔직히 모르겠습니다. 하지만
uh 저는 uh 음, 오늘 제가
그것을 조금 다르게 쓸 것이라고 말하는 것이
아닙니다
.
원래 종이지만 제 생각
에는 재구성하고 싶은 몇 가지 요점이 있다고
생각합니다. 그러나 그들은 승인하지 않습니다.
uh 저도 그가 새 논문을 가지고 있다고 생각
하지만 아마도 미래에 있지만 이것은
신화와 같은 질문이
준 것입니다.  여전히 철학적
질문
과 개념적 질문은 여전히
저를 괴롭히지만 저는 아직
이러한
아이디어를 더 신중하게 개발할 기회를 찾지 못했고 제가 제시한 일반적인
견해
도 여전히 유효하다고 생각합니다.
여전히 나는
더 자세히 설명하고
내가 얼마나 멀리 갈 수 있는지 볼 수 있는 이 기회를 기다리고 있지만
아직 모른다는 것을 인정해야 합니다.
몇 가지
고립 된
문제에  지난 몇 년 동안 이 접근 방식에
대해 저는 생태학
적인 활동가와 활동가를 위한 정보 및 과학적 이해와 정보의 개념으로 작업해 왔으며
최근에는 가상 현실 및 인식 인식
에 관해 몇 개의 대학과 최근에 협력하고 있습니다.
흥미로운 질문을 찾고 어떻게 처리할 수 있는지 알아보기 위해 연구를 수행하는 방식을 좋아
합니다
합리성 만약 내가
그것이 매우 멋진 주제라고 생각했고 uh 나는 여전히
그렇다고 생각하지만 나는
돌아와서 내가 원했던 것을 재구성할 시간
이 없었지만 uh 아마도
가까운 장래에 아마도 나는 모르지만 더
가장 최근에 작업한
것은 셀룰러 합리성과 관련이
없지만 일부 제품
은 가상 현실과 다를 수 있다고 생각
합니다.
인내심과 시각적 환경에서 분명히
빠진 것이 있기 때문에 물론 거기에 누군가가
있다면 예를 들어
내가 일종의
위협을받는 시각적 환경에 있다면 두려움과 유사한 것을 느낄 수
있지만  나는 정말로 내 삶을 두려워하지 않고
가상 현실에 있는 사람
이 위협 가상 위협
에서 도망치는
것이 합리적이라고 상상합니다.  그리고 어 어쩌면
급진적이고 능동적인
합리성에 대한 아이디어로 되돌아갈 수 있는 지점을 제공하기 때문일 수도 있습니다. 사실 어, 지난 며칠 동안
너무 바빴기 전에 말씀드린 대로 논문이 승인되었습니다.
동료와 나는 결코 비유적이지 않습니다
어 그리고 저도 지난 몇 주 동안
수정된 버전의 논문을 제출해야 하는 빡빡한 일정으로
인해서 증거를 얻었습니다.
합리성
을 갖고 싶지만
내가 모르는지 모르겠다 나는 정말로 그
발전을 예측할 수 없지만 어 일반적으로 나는
여전히 내 원래 아이디어에 동의하지만
조금 다르게 틀을 잡을 것입니다  조금
그래서 VR 포인트 거기에
더 할 말이 많다고 확신하지만 제목만 생각나게 했습니다.
가상 현실은
가상화입니다. 따라서
인지 행동 계획을
통해
우리 몸이 좋아하지 않는 정책을 즐길 수 있는 것과 같은 방식입니다.  t
그것을 평가하고 선택
하기만 하면 되지만 우리는
공상의 비행을 계속할 수 있습니다. 정신적으로 기발한 정책
선택 프로세스
가
있지만 우리의 형태는
실제로 선반에서 떨어지면 알다시피 우리의 생명선과 비슷
합니다.  상처를 입게 된
다음 가상 현실에서
지각적 경험을 구현하는 것은 말 그대로
생존에 중요한 상황의 가상화이므로
자신이 난간 위에 있는 것처럼
보일 수 있지만 평평한 바닥에
있고 그 상황에 처하게 됩니다.
당신이 비디오 게임
외부의 인지 관찰자
라면
내가 무슨 일이 일어나는지 보기 위해 넘어지는 것이
합리적이라고 말할 수도 있지만
공간 안에 합리성의 층이 있습니다. 예
, 좋은 움직임  게임에서
음, 그래서 그것은 [음악] 사이의 경계를 흐리게 하고 있습니다
.
그것은 신체의 중요성을 흐리게 하고
있고 음
저는 당신이 이것에 대해 훨씬 더 많이 생각했을 것이라고 확신합니다
.  우리가 이러한 시스템에 대해 생각하고 사용
하고 설계하는 방식
은 이것이
우리가 논문을 작성하도록 동기를 부여한 질문
이며 어 NADA는 그들에게 제공합니다.
저는 기술 문헌
에서 많은 연구원
들이  uh 시각적 인식을
일종의 Illusion으로 취급하지만 우리는
그것이 VR에서만 작동하기 때문에 그것이
우리를 위해 작동하는 장치 장치를 구현했기 때문에 약간 귀찮았습니다.
설정
하고 uh
사용자가 일종의
환상에 빠져 있다고 말하는 것이 너무 이상하게 보이지만 다른 한편으로는 실제로 인식이 아닌 것 같습니다.
예를 들어
VR에서 사과를 보면
영양이 부족하지만 게임 내에서는 이해가 되지만 실제 환경
에서 사과를 받은 것은 영양
을 제공한다는 것입니다.
그것은 내가 먹을
수 있지만 VR에서는 안되는 것입니다. 그래서 우리는
이 비행기에 대한 암시의 개념을 만들었습니다.
어 마치 우리가
실제 동물을 마주하고 있는 것처럼 보이지만 여기에는 우리가
아닌 이 생각도 포함됩니다.
우리가 게임에 참여하고 있다는 것을 알고 있는 장비를 착용하고 있기 때문에 오도되는
것입니다. 비유가 있기 때문에 이것이 지금 뜨거운 주제라고 생각합니다.
사람들이 매우 낙관적이지만
메타베의 가능성에 대해서는 매우 회의적입니다.  rs
및 일부 저자
는 엄밀히 말해서 우리가 시뮬레이션에 있을 수
있다고 생각하지만
현재 기술이
우리에게 보여주는 최고의 기술은 매우 제한적이며
특정 환경 등에서 가장할 수 있다는
것입니다.  이 시각적 환경에서 합리성에 대해
생각하는 새로운 새로운 사고 방식을 제공할 수 있습니다.
아마도
러시아인들은 환경
에서 말하는 무언가를 하고
어떤 일이 일어나는지 보는 반면
, 그렇게 하는 행동의 측면은 때때로
사람들이 실제로 느끼는 것입니다.  두려움과 사람들
은 가상 현실 공포증에 대한 거리에 직면
하고
음 그것은 많은
흥미로운 질문이 있습니다.
아마도 미래의 연구를 위해 우리가 다시 할 수 있다는 것을 의미합니다
. 현실에서 Apple이 어떻게 작동하는지 생각하게했습니다.
당신에게 칼로리가 될 수 있지만
파리에 대한 칼로리가 될
수 있습니다. 그것은 던질 수 있습니다 당신은 그것을 망치로 사용할 수 있습니다 당신은
그것을 올바르게 칠할 수 있으므로
생태 및 생성
능동적인 추론
은 항상 진행되고 있다고 말하는 프로세스는 주어진 개체
에 대해 프로그래밍된 어포던스가 무엇이든 간에
그리고
음 또한 현재 VR에 대한 담론은 헤드셋에 크게 초점을 맞추고 있습니다
.  약간 흥미로운
것은 마치 휴대전화
토론이 특정 크기의 직사각형에만 초점을 맞춘
것처럼 가상 현실이 아닌 것과 같습니다. 마치 창을 통해 보는
것과 이야기할 다른 사람
이 있어서 내 머리에 붙어 있지 않은 것과 같습니다.
일부 기술이 가지고 있는 모션 추적 기능의
일부가 있지만
Perry 개인 공간의 틈새 수정
이며 우리는
VR 프레이밍 또는 실제로
합리성과 지각
인지 행동의 프레이밍을 갖도록 신호와 어포던스
를 서로 밀어낼 수 있습니다.
특정
실현 또는 하드웨어 유형에 국한되지 않고 필드의
전체 오프라인 사람에서 s까지 범위를 실행할 수 있습니다.
매트릭스에 있는 누군가
는 꽤 관련이 있는 것 같습니다. 그렇지 않으면
작은 변형과
소프트웨어 업데이트라도 새로운 기술이 계속해서
무한한 놀라움과 혼란을 줄 것입니다. 그렇습니다
. 경계를 정의
하기가 어렵다고 생각합니다.
나는 그것이 증가할 수 있다고 생각하지만
가상 현실의 한 형태로 분류되는 것은
물론 당신이 C 정신을 망치는 것을 보고
있지만
어 내 말은 대부분은 요즘 그들이 잘하고 있다고 생각하며 그들은
헤드셋이 있어야 한다고 말함으로써 문서를 찾습니다.  그리고
때때로 컨트롤러지만 그
외의 가상 현실처럼 들리지만
네 아무 것도 정의하기가 어렵습니다. 어
그것은 덤프가 아니며 간단하지 않은
것 중 하나입니다.
왜냐하면 어 상업적으로 말하는 것은
물론 가상 현실은 헤드셋
및 기타 도구를 의미하기 때문입니다. 하지만
그 당시에는 전화나 전신으로 통화하는 전화
가 그 감각
양식과 그 어포던스를 가진 인터페이스에 있었을 것
입니다.  가상화
그렇습니다. 오늘날 우리는
다른 장에 액세스할
수 있습니다. 그렇습니다. 그렇습니다. 우리 논문의 일부는
어떤 면에서
기술 장치를 구현하는 것이
분명히 필요하다고 주장하는 것이었습니다. 그것은 새로운 것이 아니라
인간이 되기의 표식입니다.
기술적 장치 구현
분석 기술을 사용하여 처음부터 지금의 우리를 만든 것 및
예를 들어 가상 현실 내에서
우리를 제어하는 ​​생물을 더 풍부하게 갖도록 프로그래밍된 장치라 할지라도 우리가 그것을 매우 능숙하게 구현할 수 있다는 사실  새로운
형태 또 다른 형태 예를
들어 그런 경우에도
우리는 장치를 구현할 수 있기 때문에 매우 능숙하게 발생
합니다. 일부
실험
에서 예를 들어 손목의 비틀림을
세 번째 팔에 매핑할 수 있음이 나타났습니다.
어 개별 현실이 시작되는
당신의 가슴과 사람들은
우리의 실제 형태에 매핑되지
않지만 Twist o에 의해 그렇게 만들 수 있는 이 세 번째 팔을 제어하는 ​​방법을 배울 수 있습니다.  f
손목 그래서
이것은 우리가 우리 논문에서 논의할 것
입니다 잘 당신
은 그것을 할 수 있습니다 당신이 볼 수 있는 장치를 구현하기 때문에 그것이 환상임을 알 수 있습니다
그것은 실제로
제가 인간이 되는 것의 일부는 기술 장치를 자수하는 것입니다
그래서
저는  그런 식으로 갈 것입니다 내 말은 그것이 가상 및 비가상 새싹의 구별을 흐리게 한다는 것을 알고 있다는 것을 의미합니다. 그것이
이 멋진 문제를 다루는 한 가지 방법이라고 생각합니다.
질문이나 서곡의 종류에 대해 이야기하고
싶은 다른 것이 있습니까?  이 문서에 대해 토론할 수 있는 기회를 주셔서 감사합니다.
정말 즐거웠습니다.
이 문제를 논의
하고 생각할 수 있는 매우 멋지고 편안한 환경입니다. 다시 한 번
감사합니다. 예, 멋진 토론과
중요한 주제 및  우리는
언제든지 다시 이야기하게되어 기쁠 것입니다
오케이 감사합니다 안녕히 계세요 감사합니다